look
it was funny
for tom brady to say that
but
he he i don't think he ever jokes
i think for him every joke flows from
some fundamental truth and he said what
he said there was a team that was
interested and at the very end they
weren't and he thought you're sticking
with that bleepity bleep bleep and so
yesterday
everyone was trying to figure out
who he was referring to which team and
which quarterback and the leader
clearly yes is jimmy garoppolo right
clearly right because
tom brady wanted to go play yeah for the
49ers the team he rooted for growing up
he was at the catch game if you haven't
heard we just talked about the catch
game yesterday he's he was there and
witnessed drew pearson get tackled by
eric wright to save the game he wanted
to play for the 49ers they didn't want
him we put it out to a vote and
the the four finalists that i came up
with were jimmy garoppolo ryan tannehill
mitchell trubisky and drew locke whoever
voted
whoever's whoever's account that comes
from voted for drew locke um i
look i
i never heard that he wanted to go to
the broncos or the titans or even the
bears the only teams i knew about that
he was interested in were the 49ers and
the cults yeah and the colts didn't have
a quarterback then no i mean they didn't
have an m effort to stick with no you're
right there was nothing there i mean
that the obvious thought is definitely
jimmy garoppolo the 49ers everything
about that now i will say i think there
was rumors out there at the time and i
think we talked about this a little bit
about tennessee a little bit where that
was in the conversation where we thought
they maybe they were pursuing him and
thinking about it a little but yeah i
have a hard time thinking he was
thinking saying that about
tana hill who had just come off a pretty
good year too
comeback player of the year right and
tom brady in his last game with the
patriots exactly so that's where you
come back to everything you said and we
know it came down
to
you know tampa san francisco and new
england i mean that's what it was and
really other than new england it was
that 10 percent tampa san francisco
model and everything we've known or
heard anyways was hey that yeah the
49ers said hey we're going to stick with
jimmy g we just went to the super bowl
we're going to stick with him so
that's the obvious thought there there's
no doubt about it now i will say this do
we know he's definitely talking about
that right there did they we sure that's
not cut up in some sequence or something
like that to make it well you know
that's what i'm if they if they if they
did that it's very misleading and he
should be upset yes because they created
the impression yes you're right that's
what he was talking so then he probably
and i don't know what else he would have
been talking about what else would he
been talking about yeah you're right so
then when it came down to the end and
someone wasn't interested yeah i mean
yeah you're right that's the
clear implication
that everyone has reached and the only
person who has articulated it otherwise
is you and you're acting on what pete
demolitis texted yesterday that are we
sure this isn't something yeah obviously
because it does it's edited clearly they
lifted something out yeah but but it it
would be the height of unfairness to tom
brady right for that to have
dealt with something completely
unrelated to his free agency from last
year he he should be any and you know
what it was such a big deal yesterday
if it wasn't
in reference to what we all thought it
was he should have said something yeah
right he wouldn't he would have that's i
absolutely i mean that dispels that i
think we're on that this was definitely
tangible and it was a team he was
interested in and yeah like for people
that are out there i want to go i hear
the bears and people saying that i want
to go like
i i don't know i never heard any inkling
that tom brady was even remotely
interested in the chicago bears what all
the questions about their offense and
their offensive line and inability to
run the ball and everything you know
everybody's questioned that side of the
ball in chicago the last two years i
don't think that was the place he was
looking at going let me go there to the
unproven not really talented side of the
football in chicago and do that no that
was never so i don't i don't think that
mitchell trubisky is part of the
conversation i mean it just seems like
all signs are pointed towards jimmy g
and i don't know maybe he won't get him
invited to the kentucky derby next year
either
i and and some have argued well it was
he was clearly joking around he was
trying to get a rise out of the other
folks he's trying to make for good tv
that's fine yeah that's fine but he
still said it yeah he still said it
right
no still set right you're right so yes
so that's it is what it is but yes i
think everybody's gonna continue to
think that's jimmy garoppolo that he's
referring to for sure
hopefully
when
the buccaneers convene for training camp
someone in the press corps
will remember to ask him tom
who is the
mfer to whom you were referring and
we'll see what he has to say about that
because surely he'll be asked about it
it it created such a stir yesterday and
will continue to do so that it's not
going to be forgotten by the next time
he's in front of a camera or a
microphone surely he'll be asked about
it at some point but uh we'll see and i
doubt that he'll be candid about it but
uh
uh he still needs to be asked the
question um and uh it it it makes four
interesting times as he continues his
career going forward
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports